nous voyons certainement comment il est pompé
tensions entre la Chine
et les États-Unis
voir qui, comme on dit, joue en premier
dans ce violon pas tres agreable
développement d'événements et nous c'est en général
sûr de déranger toute confrontation
les régimes n'aident pas à vivre une vie normale
la population de notre planète commune, qu'elle
annoncé il n'y a pas si longtemps
Les stratégies du Pacifique qui directement
ont proclamé leur tâche principale
l'une des tâches principales du confinement
le développement de la chine contient
Mer de Chine méridionale, que ce soit celle-ci
le code même qui se trouve dans ces
stratégies
formé ou, soit dit en passant, triple
le syndicat qui était maintenant aussi
a proclamé l'australie états-unis
et la Grande-Bretagne et l'objectif aident également
l'australie dissuade la menace chinoise je
rencontré aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui hier avec
plusieurs ministres qui
représentent d'étranges membres de l'association
états d'asie du sud-est asean
Je m'intéressais particulièrement à eux
la situation est entre la Chine et les Russes
Oui, pas rapidement, mais il y a une négociation
le processus de préparation des gens pour un dîner et
code de conduite contraignant en
La mer de Chine méridionale est probablement la plus
moyen fiable d'assurer la liberté
expédition et tout ce qui s'inquiète
nos partenaires occidentaux pour ce qu'ils
certains permanents
provocateur et non provocateur
manœuvres navales et
créer ces géopolitiques
ces diagrammes sont chinois